hate inspired leadership NAACP joins
other other groups and warning against
travel to Florida this is a Miami Herald
story from yesterday the oldest civil
group Civil Rights group in the U.S has
issued a travel advisory urging
travelers to reconsider this in Florida
due to the states openly hostile
leadership significantly specifically
citing Governor Ron DeSantis attempts to
ban books
about race and lgbtq identities in his
opposition to diversity and inclusion
programs and colleges NAACP Derek
Johnson president argues that the
refusal to teach an accurate
representation of channel of the
challenges faced by African Americans is
a disservice to students and a neglect
of Duty other civil rights organizations
such as lulac and equality Florida have
also shoot Travel warnings for Florida
citing concerns over the Santa's
Crackdown of immigration and the
potential risks to health safety and
freedom however tourism in Florida
remain strong with record numbers of
visitors and local leaders emphasized
their City's commitment to diversity
inclusion by the way I wouldn't even be
surprised if the NAACP isn't staying at
Miami for uh summertime
Jesse what is it a thing on his show
last night yeah that chairwoman just
posted from Twitter her holiday her
vacation in Florida yeah exactly you see
right these are politically motivated
no this is a political boy caught that
has no teeth whatsoever Budweiser is
down by by some estimates 28 thanks to
the Bud Light boycott which has been
very effective and very welcomed by
Coors and competitors on one hand on the
other hand you look at the diversity in
Florida you look at diversity at the
beaches someone didn't get the memo that
you were supposed to boycott and maybe
go to some other place
how about Chicago why don't we boycott
you know Chicago 22 people shot last
weekend and I can guarantee you that
most of those are black Americans so
aren't we boycotting Chicago or
Baltimore the the average weekend on
Chicago is 10 people killed and 50 shot
the average weekend but the NAACP
straight back lives matter doesn't care
about the people being killed in Chicago
it's just hypocrisy yeah I don't think
this travel ban is doing anything or
this travel warning is doing anything to
mitigate people from traveling to
Florida whether it's the Panhandle
whether going to Disney World in Orlando
where they're coming to South Beach in
Miami people are coming nobody's like
you know that vacation we've been
working on for the last two months for
the summer let's go yeah there's the
NAACP made this warning but they're like
dude we're going to party stop it yeah
you say that but I literally had a guest
that's scheduled for your podcast that
sent an email yesterday hey bro I want
to confirm it's safe for me and my
family to travel there still I'm seeing
this over the internet and news I'm
coming with my girlfriend and our two
sons is it safe or should we reschedule
and then they included an Instagram post
to the nation don't say the name can you
text me the name who it is by the way
yes can you text me and meanwhile show
the show the meme I just sent you a guy
sent me this I thought it was that's
wild something very interesting uh uh uh
to think about tulsi's Texan right now
but can you can you post this real quick
uh
which which makes you think and by the
way whether you like this meme or nod
there is a lot of truth behind this meme
uh here's what the meme has done I don't
know if you've seen this one uh take a
look at this Adam what's tallest texting
yes white victim nobody cares black is
silent black victim nobody cares black
is silent white victim nobody cares
white is selling black victim
people lose their minds there's your
news there's your mainstream media uh
narrative that's the narrative that they
will support that's Neely that's that's
the filter for the stories right yeah
yeah no it but this this is what makes
you and by the way uh didn't they just
have a 25 000 Haitians had an event here
happy doing an event in Florida right
you look at the crime on what's going on
you look at how many people are moving
here to Florida statistically that
argument loses a lot of weight when they
say you got to be careful moving to
Florida I love it how people can say
things like that but data argues
completely the other way than you do
this is what happened with Newsome
Newsome talk about how terrible Florida
is more people the more he talks
about Florida the more people from
California wanted to move to Florida and
it's not slowing down and by the way
this is due to a great Governor a guy
named Ron DeSantis thanks to Donald
Trump so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign